good morning John in August of 2019 the
New York Times published an article that
was titled why hate speech on the
Internet is a never-ending problem
because this law Shields the law in
question was section 230 of the
communications decency act later that
day they published The Following
retraction an earlier version of this
article incorrectly described the law
that protects hate speech on the
internet the First Amendment not section
230 of the communications decency act
protects it now this is kind of funny
it's also kind of not especially if you
know the long history of people
misunderstanding section 230 and what it
means it is very difficult for all of us
to figure out how to adjust to the power
that the internet wields and when we're
doing that it's pretty easy to look
toward what's probably the most
important piece of legislation in the
history of the internet which was passed
as part of a much larger bill when Mark
Zuckerberg was 11 years old and then
when he was 12 years old almost all of
that law was declared unconstitutional
by the Supreme Court but they left one
section
section 230 which says among other
things this no provider or user of an
interactive Computer Service shall be
treated as the publisher or speaker of
any information provided by another
information content provider to explain
right now I am the other information
content provider and YouTube is the
provider of the interactive Computer
Service and so if I slander someone or
try to recruit someone to my terrorist
cell or otherwise do something illegal
you can sue or find or imprison me you
can't hold YouTube liable for what I
said this thing section 230 is kind of
what made it possible for the many to
many internet thing to exist which is
good but also bad it's the thing that we
love about the internet and it's the
thing that we hate about the internet
right now the Supreme Court is hearing a
case against YouTube that argues that
YouTube is not liable for the content in
the videos on its platform but it is
liable for the recommendations of that
content to people if the YouTube
algorithm recommends terrorist
recruitment videos to YouTube users it
isn't just hosting content it's also
kind of creating a new kind of content
which is the recommendation and that
seems a little bit right to me the
problem though is where do you draw the
line for what counts as a recommendation
is a Google search a list of
recommendations that Google is making to
me does that mean that every internet
platform that has a recommendation
system of any kind meaning all of them
are they liable for what they
recommended if they are does the
internet work at all it looks like the
Supreme Court will not find YouTube
liable in this case which I think is
good but the reality is that there is
something of a difference between the
front page of YouTube being
algorithmically generated for each
individual user and me searching for
something and getting recommended
results and maybe there's a difference
between those two things and chat GPT
creating content that I will then read
that was nonetheless created by a
machine there's definitely a way to see
recommendation as creation I just don't
think that a law passed in 1996 did a
good job of anticipating that and
actually I think that that law had a
tremendous amount of foresight and has
served us fairly well there was a moment
when the Supreme Court was talking about
this when Justice Kagan said something
that I want to play for you now you know
every other industry has to internalize
the costs of misconduct why is it that
the tech industry gets a pass on the
other hand I mean we're a court we
really don't know about these things
you know these are not like the nine
greatest experts on the internet
the implication being we probably
shouldn't be trying to figure this stuff
out based on 26 words that were written
in 1996. it should be decided by passing
new legislation that considers the
internet as it exists now which is
pretty different from when there are
interactive Computer Services I think
that we're actually pretty dang lucky
that section 230 supported the creation
of this new tool of many-to-many
communication which has I admit
drawbacks but I don't think anybody's
figured out like a good and simple way
to tease all the bad parts out from the
good parts and the times that we've
attempted to do that haven't had great
outcomes it's very hard to legislate for
a world that changes this quickly so if
it feels sometimes like we don't know
how to do this
it's because we don't know how to do it
John I'll see you on Tuesday